why are we still here why why are we
here so are we doing it you're doing
another one oh yes
Oh documentary Short subject that's a
good one all right that's the good one
here are the nominees black sheep Ed
Perkins and Jonathan chin and game Rob
Epstein and Jeffrey Friedman lifeboat
Skye Fitzgerald and brynn Moussa a night
at the garden
Marshall curry period end of sentence
Rika's Itachi and Melissa Burton and the
Oscar goes to
period end of sentence
this is the first Oscar and nomination
for Vikas the table she and Marisa Bert
[Applause]
I'm not crying because I'm on my period
or anything I can't believe a film about
menstruation just won an Oscar
thank you thank you thanks for giving us
a part more thank you to my creative
partner Sam Davis I share this with you
baby thank you to my mom and my sister I
love you guys too Lisa Tabak
and Karen chef Takumi manga and the
women of kata cara know that you who are
empowering women all over the world to
fight for menstral equality this film
began because high-school students here
and our partners at action India wanted
to make a difference a human rights
difference I share this award with the
feminist majority foundation with Helen
Claire Avery Ruby Sophie Charlotte Carly
the entire pad project team uh with the
Oakwood school I share this I share this
with teachers and with students around
the world a period should end a sentence
not a girls education
[Applause]